I WANT TO HAND IT TO SARAH
SNYDER.
>> I AM SARAH SNYDER, AND THIS
IS "CNN TONIGHT."
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA IS BEING
HIT ON THREE DIFFERENT FRONTS
FOR SENDING ASYLUM SEEKERS FROM
TEXAS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
TODAY HE WAS HIT WITH A CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT.
HE'S ALREADY FACING A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, AND THEN THERE
ARE QUESTIONS FROM THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
MISUSE OF STATE FUNDS.
LET'S START WITH THE CIVIL SUIT.
THAT'S COMING FROM A LEGAL GROUP
REPRESENTING MORE THAN 30 OF THE
ASYLUM SEEKERS, FIEMG A CLAIM
AGAINST GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
AND OTHER STATE OFFICIALS SAYING
THAT THE MIGRANTS EXPERIENCED,
QUOTE, CRUELTY AKIN TO WHAT THEY
FLED IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY OF
VENEZUELA.
IT CLAIMS FLORIDA OFFICIALS
MANIPULATED THEM, STRIPPED THEM
OF THEIR DIGNITY, DEPRIVED THEM
OF THEIR LIBERTY, BODILY
AUTONOMY DUE PROCESS UNDER THE
LAW.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CLAIM.
BASICALLY THEY SAY DeSANTIS
LIED.
AND THEIR LAWYERS ARE LOOKING
INTO THESE BROCHURES USED TO
ENTICE THOSE SEEKING A BETTER
LIFE TO TRAVEL UNDER THE GUISE
THAT RESETTLEMENT SUPPORT WAS
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THE GOVERNOR KEEPS INSISTING THE
ASYLUM SEEKERS KNEW WHAT THEY
WERE SIGNING UP FOR.
IT WAS ALL VOLUNTARY AND HE
CLAIMED THE HUMANE THING TO DO.
>> THOSE MIGRANTS WERE BEING
TREATED HORRIBLY BY BIDEN.
THEY WERE HUNGRY, HOMELESS, THEY
HAD NO OPPORTUNITY AT ALL.
THE STATE OF FLORIDA -- IT WAS
VOLUNTEER.
THEY WERE PROVIDED AN ABILITY TO
BE IN THE MOST POSH SANCTUARY
JURISDICTION MAYBE IN THE WORLD.
>> THE STRANGE THING TO BE SUED
BY PEOPLE WHO SAYS WERE INFORMED
VOLUNTEERS.
AND THAT ALLEGATION OF A LIE
TAKES US TO THE SECOND FRONT
WHERE DeSANTIS IS GETTING HIT.
THE SHERIFF OF BEHAR COUNTY
ANNOUNCED AN INVESTIGATION INTO
HOW MIGRANTS GOT FROM TEXAS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THE ELECTED SHERIFF WHO IS A
DEMOCRAT TOLD REPORTERS THAT THE
MIGRANTS WHO TOOK THE FLIGHTS
WERE EXPLOITED AND, IN HIS
WORDS, HOODWINKED.
>> WHAT I'M TRYING TO DETERMINE
RIGHT NOW IS WAS THE LAW BROKEN
HERE IN TEXAS, NAMELY, IN BEHAR
COUNTY WHERE I'M THE SHERIFF.
I DO FROM WHAT WE'RE HEARING,
PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH HIM OR EMPLOYED
BY HIM OR CONTRACTED BY HIM OR
HIS FOLKS MAY HAVE BROKEN THE
LAW HERE IN BEXAR COUNTY.
>> THERE ARE BIG QUESTIONS IN
FLORIDA AS WELL.
THAT'S FRONT NUMBER THREE.
DID DeSANTIS MISUSE STATE FUNDS
FOR THIS?
HERE IS THE STATE BUDGET
LANGUAGE.
$12 MILLION WAS APPROPRIATED TO
FLORIDA'S TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENT TO FACILITATE THE
TRANSPORT OF, QUOTE,
UNAUTHORIZED ALIENS FROM THIS
STATE CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
LAW.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO THAT
HIGHLIGHTED PART THAT YOU SEE
THERE IN YELLOW.
UNAUTHORIZED ALIENS AND FROM
THIS STATE, MEANING FLORIDA.
THE MEN AND WOMEN AND CHILDREN
AREN'T UNAUTHORIZED ALIENS, THEY
ARE LEGAL ASYLUM SEEKERS, AND
THIS STATE, WHICH WOULD BE
FLORIDA, IS NOT TEXAS.
TO BE CLEAR, THERE IS A CRISIS
AT THE BORDER.
THE WHITE HOUSE ADMITS AS MUCH
AND THERE IS A REPORT SHOWING 2
MILLION ARRESTS AT THE BORDER
OVER THE LAST 11 MONTHS.
THAT IS A RECORD.
SO THERE IS A PROBLEM, BUT IT IS
HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC HOW SOME OF
THESE RED-STATE GOVERNORS ARE
GOING ABOUT SOLVING IT.
THAT IS A QUESTION WE WANT TO
GET INTO NOW.
I'M JOINED BY RAUL REYES,
IMMIGRATION LAWYER AND JOHN
AVLON AND FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF
TO THE HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY UNDER THEN-PRESIDENT
TRUMP, MYLES TAYLOR MYLES, I
WANT TO START WITH YOU.
WITH THIS KIND OF POLITICAL
GAMEMANSHIP WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
SCARED, WHO ARE DESPERATE, WHO
ARE LEGALLY IN THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY ARE SEEKING ASYLUM,
DID THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
EVER THINK OF DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THIS, AND IF NOT, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT THESE TWO
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE DECIDED
THAT THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO, PARTICULARLY DeSANTIS WHO
WENT INTO ANOTHER STATE AND SENT
PEOPLE FROM ANOTHER STATE
SOMEWHERE THAT THEY SAY THEY HAD
NO IDEA WHERE THEY WERE GOING?
>> WELL, SARAH, NOT ONLY DID THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, I THINK
THEY'RE THE PROGENITORS OF THE
CONCEPT.
THIS IS A ZOMBIE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION POLICY THAT HAD
DIED AND HAS NOW COME BACK TO
LIFE.
AND THESE TWO GOVERNORS HAVE
BROUGHT IT BACK TO LIFE.
I'LL TELL YOU EXACTLY WHEN THIS
HAPPENED.
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY OF 2019,
DONALD TRUMP DIRECTED US TO GO
AND TAKE IMMIGRANTS FROM THE
BORDER AND, QUOTE, BUS AND DUMP
THEM INTO DEMOCRATIC CITIES AND
BLUE STATES.
HE WANTED US TO TAKE IMMIGRANTS
FROM THE BORDER, TAKE THEM INTO
BLUE STATES AND CITIES, BUT HE
WAS MORE SPECIFIC.
HE WANTED US TO IDENTIFY THE
MURDERERS, THE RAPISTS, AND THE
CRIMINALS, AND IF PARTICULAR,
MAKE SURE WE DID NOT INCARCERATE
THEM.
WE PUT THEM IN THOSE CITIES.
OKAY.
IT DOESN'T TAKE A LAWYER OR A
JENSEN TO RECOGNIZE THIS WOULD
LIKELY BE VERY ILLEGAL TO DO,
BUT PUT ASIDE THE MURDERS AND
THE RAPISTS AND THE CRIMINALS,
COULD YOU TAKE PEOPLE FROM THE
BORDER AND DUMP THEM INTO BLUE
STATES.
WE ASKED THE LAWYERS AND THEY
TOLD US, NO, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CANNOT DO THAT.
CONGRESS HAS NOT AUTHORIZED
THAT.
THE GOVERNORS ARE WALKING INTO
THE SAME PROBLEM THAT WE TOLD
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS ILLEGAL AND
THEY COULDN'T DO, AND NOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THE SAME
THING.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
TAKING THIS COURSE AND WHY IS IT
THAT THIS KIND OF CRUELTY IS
COMING FROM ONE PARTICULAR
PARTY, THE REPUBLICANS RIGHT
NOW?
THIS IS CRUELTY TO THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING ASYLUM IN THIS COUNTRY,
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE QUITE
PROUD OF AS A COUNTRY OR HAVE
BEEN?
>> LOOK, YOU CAN DISAGREE ON
IMMIGRATION AND I STILL THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD BE PROUD OF FACT
THAT 2 MILLION PEOPLE WANT BADLY
TO COME INTO THIS COUNTRY.
BUT THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO TREAT
THEM ONCE THEY GET HERE.
WHY ARE THEY DOING IT?
THE ANSWER IS SIMPLE.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T WANT TO DO
IT BECAUSE IT WAS GOING TO SOLVE
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER TO FLY
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THESE TWO GOVERNORS ARE CARRYING
FORWARD THE TORCH OF TRUMPISM,
BUT THEY'RE DOING MORE THAN
CARRYING THE TORCH FORWARD,
THEY'RE SELF-EMULATING WITH THAT
TORCH TO FUND RAISE.
THAT'S AN EXTRA LAYER IN MY
OPINION OF GROTESQUENESS WHEN IT
COMES TO PUBLIC POLICY.
>> SEEMS TO BE WORKING WITH THE
BASE.
RAUL, LEGALLY WHAT IS THE REMEDY
FOR A GOVERNOR WHO MAY BE
EXCEEDING HIS AUTHORITY IN TERMS
OF IMMIGRATION AND HE'S GOING
INTO A DIFFERENT STATE SENDING
ASYLUM SEEKERS INTO YET A
DIFFERENT STATE?
WHAT IS THE LEGAL REMEDY HERE
FOR HIM?
>> FOR THE GOVERNOR OR FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION?
>> FOR THE ADMINISTRATION?
>> WELL, I THINK THESE LAWSUITS
THAT WE SEE NOW ARE JUST THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE IT IS
ESTABLISHED LAW, THE SUPREME
COURT, THE CONSTITUTION THAT THE
STATES DO NOT HAVE JURISDICTION
OVER IMMIGRATION.
YOU KNOW, THAT IS A FEDERAL
MATTER.
THE REASON WE HAVEN'T SEEN
ACTION IS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO GIVE AIR TO THIS ISSUE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE FOR THE GOP
POLITICALLY, FOR INSTANCE IS A
GREAT ISSUE BECAUSE IT KEEPS
PEOPLE FROM TALKING ABOUT THE
ASSAULT ON REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
AND ABORTION.
IT KEEPS PEOPLE FROM TALKING
ABOUT DeDANTIS' MOVES AGAINST
LGBTQ PEOPLE IN FLORIDA.
BUT RIGHT NOW, I MEAN, THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT -- BASICALLY
WHAT THESE GOVERNORS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO IS DEPORTING
PEOPLE FROM THEIR STATE TO
ANOTHER STATE.
LOOK, TRUE, GOVERNORS CAN MOVE
MIGRANTS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
PAST ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE DONE
THAT IN COORDINATION AND WITH
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WHAT THEY CANNOT DO IS JUST TAKE
A TARGETED GROUP OF PEOPLE,
TRANSPORT THEM ALLEGEDLY THROUGH
FRAUDULENT OR DECEPTIVE MEANS.
THERE IS A COMMERCIAL GAIN
INVOLVED TO THE CONTRACTORS WHO
FLEW THEM THERE.
RIGHT THERE YOU HAVE THE
ELEMENTS OF A CASE OF
TRAFFICKING.
THAT'S SIMILAR TO THE CASE THAT
THE LAWYERS COMMUNITY FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS IS BRINGING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT DeSANTIS
IS SAYING NOW -- AND HE SAID IT
A FEW TIMES TO DO, IS THAT THEY
AGREED TO THE TRANSPORT.
BUT IN CASES OF TRAFFICKING,
YOUR ACCEPTANCE, YOUR
WILLINGNESS, YOUR CONSENT IS NOT
A DEFENSE.
>> RIGHT, BECAUSE YOU'RE UNDER
PRESSURE.
>> RIGHT, BECAUSE YOU DID NOT
HAVE FULL KNOWLEDGE OF THE
FACTS.
THAT IS NOT A DEFENSE TO THESE
ALLEGATIONS, TO THESE IMPROPER
USES OF AUTHORITY.
>> I'M CURIOUS, JOHN.
HAVE WE EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE WHERE YOU'RE SEEING
GOVERNORS SENDING PEOPLE FROM
ONE STATE TO THE NEXT WITHOUT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVING
ANY IDEA WHERE THEY'RE GOING?
>> LOOK, I MEAN, FIRST OF ALL, I
DO THINK PART OF IT IS AN EFFORT
TO ROLL BACK ISSUES THAT HAD
BEEN PREVIOUSLY BEEN FEDERAL
ISSUES WITHIN LIVING MEMORY AND
STORE POWER TO THE STATE.
THAT'S PART OF THE PROJECT
BEYOND THE TROLL POLITICS OF
THIS.
PROBLEM IS WHEN YOU'RE POLITICS
ARE TRYING TO OUTTROLL THE OTHER
GUY, YOU'RE RUNNING INTO
PROBLEMS.
ONE PRECEDENT WAS HIGHLIGHTED BY
THE JFK LIBRARY WHERE IN A TWEET
THEY POSTED AN ARTICLE ABOUT THE
REVERSE FREEDOM RIDES PUT OUT BY
THE WHITE COUNCILS WHERE BLACK
FAMILIES WERE BEING PUT ON BUSES
BY THESE GROUPS AND SENT NORTH
TO HYANNIS PORT WHERE THE
KENNEDYS LIVED, WHERE DIFFERENT
MEMBERS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SENIOR LEADERSHIP
PARTICULARLY ON CIVIL RIGHTS
LIVED.
WITH THE ATTITUDE THAT YOU'LL BE
FAR MORE WELCOMING AND
ACCOMMODATING OF THESE FAMILIES,
MOCKING THE IDEA OF TRYING TO
ADVANCE EQUAL RIGHTS.
LOOK, THAT ISN'T PRESUMABLY -- I
THINK ALMOST CERTAINLY AN
UNINTENTIONAL ECHO.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS UP WITH
THE MUSCLE MEMORY?
YOU KNOW, THE REASON YOU PAY
ATTENTION -- MARK TWAIN ALWAYS
SAID HISTORY DOESN'T R